[MUSIC PLAYING]
JILL EBSTEIN: So I'm going
to start off with just
a small background here.
"At My Pace" is a series.
I didn't envision myself doing
this so much, but it became so,
and every time I
do another book,
it adds meaning at
least to my life.
And it began when I took
on the Sheryl Sandberg
"Lean In" conversation.
I wanted to expand it to be
more about the range of choices
we make in our life.
Some people, I say,
are leaning in,
going on the Autobahn
full speed ahead.
Others have a more winding path.
And my objective was that
we celebrate all our choices
and that we reserve judgment.
And that was this
book right here.
And so the cover is about
blue sky and open roads.
That's how we should
see our world-- blue sky
and open roads.
And then I thought it was done.
And then the next
thing that happened
was that my mother
was ailing, she
was coming on the
end of her life.
And I wanted to elevate
the conversation
from focusing on her to
something more meaningful.
So I asked people
the question, what's
one lesson you take
from your mother
and how it's impacted your life?
And that gave us a
really rich conversation.
And I found out, by the way,
that mothers and their kids
have way more complex
relationships than I
probably realized at the time.
And that was book two.
And this was about showing
your gratitude or, as I say,
giving either a flower
or an olive branch
as you find comfort and
peace in your relationship
with your mom.
So now I had two
books and the marketer
in me said, well,
now you probably
need to start thinking
about a tag line.
And I thought about that.
And so what the "At My
Pace" series is about is,
at its heart, it's
about personal stories.
And then from there we were
able to have an expanded
conversation.
And from there, hopefully
there's emerging insights.
So it's stories,
conversation insights.
Now I feel like I'm having
a tag line start to happen.
And then after that, I was
not quite sure I wanted to do,
but I realized that I have a
lot of millennials in my life.
I have three children
and a son-in-law.
So I think technically I have
four millennials in my life.
And on good days,
I understand them.
On other days I'm perplexed by
the way they frame their world.
But I don't fall prey
to the generalizations
that we always hear
about millennials.
These are some of the ones--
social media-obsessed,
narcissistic,
want to get there fast.
You can imagine all the
ones that you've heard.
And I wanted to hear
from them themselves
how they look at their world,
what their challenges are,
and what we as baby
boomers can glean from it.
And also, what they can
share among themselves
that will help them as
they find their way.
So just in terms of the "At My
Pace" format, what happens is
they're 1,000 word
pieces roughly,
they're story oriented.
I give guidelines and
I help contributors
get their pieces together as
much or as little as they need.
And so I came up with some
guidelines for this one.
Lisie, who's right here,
she's my first contributor.
She was an awesome one.
There's 29.
And so what I wanted to do today
is talk about what I learned
and what you do with it.
And I'm hoping that we can
have a conversation about this.
I would like this
to be informal and I
would like you guys to
ask questions or give me
your thoughts as you hear them.
So I'm going to start
off by just giving you
some of the titles.
There's 29 pieces in here.
I'm going to give you
some of the titles
to give you a feeling
for what I heard.
And I want to see whether--
raise your hand if
any of these either
resonate with you or you know
somebody close in your life
who you think they
could have meaning for.
So these are some of the titles.
"A Layered Identity."
"When The World Tells You No."
"Detours."
"Imposter Syndrome."
"Finding The Power of Me."
"A Series of New Beginnings."
"A Clash of Perception
and Reality."
"How To Love Myself."
"The Start and The Restart."
"Turning Caring Into Doing"
And "Keeping The Faith."
So those are just some.
And what was exceptional to
me about these contributors
is it was a look at their lives
in the most uncurated way.
They were extremely honest.
When you read this
book, you'll see
that there's a fair
bit of anxiety,
some depression, some stress,
tremendous uncertainty,
self-doubt.
All the things that we--
I know as a baby boomer,
I have felt for years.
But our 20-somethings feel that.
And they explain
where it comes from
and what they're doing with it.
So I think the best
way for me to begin
is to describe the first piece
in the book and the last piece
in the book.
Because I think it really
frames the discussion well.
The first piece is
"Purposeful Prisons."
Lisie wrote that.
One of the questions I
asked these contributors is,
what is a book, a
poem, a song, something
that resonates with you?
I wanted a quick insight into
the window of their soul.
So tell me what that would be.
And they could or
could not use it.
It didn't matter to
me, but at least it
helped me to understand
who they were.
And so Lisie right
away said, oh, William
Wordsworth, "Nuns Fret Not."
Now, I was an English major.
I happened to like
Wordsworth, but I did not
recognize that poem.
And it's a wonderful poem.
In "Nuns Fret Not,"
it's really about
how the constraints
in our life sometimes
give us purpose and meaning.
And so Wordsworth discusses
how nuns, like convents,
have poets like sonnets--
they're 14 lines-- and how
while some people might
find those boundaries
constraining, infringing
upon the things you
want to do, Wordsworth
argues that those
boundaries are purposeful.
They're purposeful
prisons that anchor you.
And Lisie, who describes
being a software
engineer, a ballet dancer,
and an observant Jew
has plenty of
boundaries in her life.
But for Lisie, those
boundaries are purposeful.
So she makes the case
for those anchors--
those very strong anchors--
being a good thing in her life.
The last piece in the
book is called "Color
Outside The Lines"
by Kimberly Rhoten.
She is the oldest
of the contributors.
She went to UC--
University of
Chicago Law School.
Did really well,
had her pick of jobs
at law firms when she graduated.
Deeply cares about the
social issues of our day.
Wants her life to be
dedicated to the social issues
of the day.
And so she picked
what she thought
was one of the most progressive,
left-leaning law firms
that she could find
that she could work in.
But it didn't last
very long for her.
Even that did not work.
And so she leaves the
law firm and she goes
and she fights for the
social issues, which
include immigration rights,
sex worker rights, health care
advocacy.
And she finds her way--
today she is the Assistant
Director at Northeastern Law
School for policy.
But in the course
of all that, she
discovered that she loves to
paint, she loves to dance,
she came out.
There's a whole
sharing of her life
and a sharing of who
she wants to be--
who she is.
And so there aren't too
many boundaries for her.
For her it's about
expressing yourself and being
true to who you are.
And so we have on one
side "Purposeful Prisons."
On another side "Color
Outside The Lines,"
which she literally is.
She paints with her
fingers, and figuratively,
as she makes choices in her
life that defy some of the more
traditional choices.
So we had that on the other end.
So the question is for these
contributors-- for these 29,
where do I fit in and
what are my challenges
in finding that place
where I can find peace,
truth to who I am, support
for the things I believe in?
I think that's the challenge.
By the way, I also was able
to survey this group, which
this is the first
of the books that I
surveyed my contributors.
In the previous ones I
just took their stories
and went from there.
But I wanted a
little bit of data
because, after all, we
live in a world of data
and it's what I do
in my day job anyway.
So I read through the stories--
worked through these stories,
and as I stepped back
and looked at them, I found
that there are basically
five parts of what I
think the contributors had
to conquer and manage
to get to a place
that they felt good about.
So the first one is just
about being healthy.
It's about being
emotionally healthy,
it's about being
physically healthy,
it's about feeling like
you're standing firm
on your own two feet with energy
and purpose and ready to go.
That actually doesn't sound
that hard, but very hard.
And one of the early
pieces I worked on
was a woman named Pam
[? Skop, ?] and she writes
a piece called "Heal Thyself."
And what happened
was I met her sister,
and her sister said
to me, you need
to get a hold of my sister.
She has a piece in her.
It would be very helpful,
very therapeutic.
I think you should talk to her.
So I did talk to
her and I'm just
going to read you the beginning
of her piece, "Heal Thyself."
She's 28, so she's older in
this range of 20-somethings.
I found that the older
you were in your 20s,
the more you had
to share or more
willing you were to share
what you had to offer.
So this is what Pam
says, "In June of 2017,
I was a bridesmaid for
the fifth time in my life.
I bought another
expensive dress,
got my hair and makeup
done, and smiled
as I walked down the aisle on
the happiest day of someone
else's life.
I looked around the room
at this group of friends
and realized how far we
had come since high school.
Six of the group
of 10 were married,
with one more couple on
the way in a few months.
One couple was
expecting a child.
Another had moved to Stanford,
Connecticut and gotten a dog.
Most everyone was becoming
established in their careers.
These people were dear friends
and we shared a common history,
but in that moment I couldn't
help but feel pretty far
from their realities."
So what happens to Pam is,
she continues to do her life,
but she looks at
herself all the time
and feels like she's
not attractive.
She wants to eat less.
She ends up having some
kind of an eating disorder.
She cries.
Her mother says to
her, we have to get
you help-- this is not OK.
And Pam agrees.
And so through a combination of
therapy, meditation, and yoga,
she finds her peace and she
understands herself far better.
And what she says at
the end of her piece
is that the hard work of
her 20s has paid off for her
and has laid the
groundwork for what
she thinks will be a much more
positive, much more energizing
30s.
And she's looking forward
to taking advantage
of the foundation she's laid.
And what she really wants
to do is help others
who suffer like her.
She became a licensed
yoga instructor.
She's going through
other training.
And what she intends to
do is to pay it forward,
because she knows how long and
how hard her path was and she
wants to be able to help others.
So step one is being healthy.
And you'll see when you read
the book, the second piece
in the book is called
"Sliding Doors."
It's about a young man in
college who falls off a balcony
and has serious trauma and
has to relearn his gait,
he has to relearn so many
things that we take for granted.
And so he's also looking back at
his life and the sliding doors.
Because it was going
this way and then it
went that way, so
all of a sudden
he sees his life
very differently.
And he has the same idea,
which is get healthy and then
pay this forward.
And all the people in his
life who have helped him--
which is quite a large team--
feel that there's now
new meaning in their life
as they realize what you can do
for others and also, the fight
that people have
to have in them.
So healthy is job one.
But the second one--
which I saw some
hands raised on--
is about managing rejection.
And for these
20-somethings, many of them
grew up in families
where they were
told they can do everything,
the world's their oyster.
We tried to groom them
for the most possible
successful outcomes ever.
We tried to make sure that
they wouldn't experience too
much failure if any failure.
We tried to make their
life just smooth as silk.
And of course, that's
not the way the world is.
And so I'm talking
to a journalist,
his name is Sam Tabachnik.
He worked for "The
Washington Post."
He was a contractor
journalist-- a very happy one.
They told him,
well, probably when
the contract runs out we'll
be able to get you signed on
as an employee.
But as you can imagine,
it did not happen.
So now he's faced with
trying to figure out
what he's going to do next.
And you probably know that
journalism is not the easiest
of places to land another job.
And so he sends email after
email and has coffee--
he talks about how many cups of
coffee he has to try to network
to land his next job.
And all he feels is
rejection facing him.
And he writes this.
He says, "Frankly, I just wasn't
used to this kind of repeated
rejection.
Growing up, I might get rejected
from a travel soccer team,
but there was always
another team to join.
I went to schools where
the teachers nurtured us.
Pretty much everyone
got A's and B's.
There wasn't a need for
a ton of tough love."
So the question is what
to do next, because he
wasn't finding a job.
He needed both money
and purpose in his life.
So he became a Lyft driver.
This was not anything
he ever imagined.
He doesn't actually love driving
because he finds the traffic
to be very burdensome.
But what he discovered was that
when he was driving people,
he loved talking to them.
And he loved almost
interviewing them
to see what was going on with
them, what they were about.
And in that way it
confirmed for him
that journalism and reporting
is really what he's about.
And so he continued
to be a Lyft driver
until he found his job in
journalism-- another job
for a smaller paper.
And so it ended up being, he
worked his way through it.
But when the world
tells you no, it's
about not expecting the
rejection you're about to feel.
And I feel that was a theme that
made it through so many pieces
in this book--
how to manage
rejection, the surprise
of it all, how to pick
yourself up and just
keep on going forward.
So in terms of the challenges
that these contributors had
to conquer to get
to a good place,
one was emotional
and physical health.
Another one was understanding
and experiencing rejection
and being able to make
your way through it.
But there's a third one,
which I think both the parents
and the kids share.
And that's called the
burden of expectations.
We expect so much from them
and they expect so much
from themselves, too.
And when you live under
these high expectations,
there's almost only
one place to go.
And so I'm going to read you
the beginning of another piece.
So back to my
asking people, what
is a song, a poem,
a book, something
that resonates with you?
In the piece called "A Clash
Of Perception and Reality,"
Gavriel Remz starts
the following.
He says, "There's a delightfully
smug scene in season four
of 'The Office,' where Ryan
Howard has been promoted
to the corporate office
in New York City.
Ryan's climb up the ladder
means he will supervise
his former boss, Michael Scott.
Clearly pleased
with his progress,
Ryan looks into the
camera and says,
people keep calling
me a wunderkind.
I don't even know
what that means.
I mean, I know what it means.
It means I'm very
successful at your age.
So it makes sense."
And then Gavriel says, "I
thought I was just like Ryan--
skipping a dozen
steps on my way up.
I craved the satisfaction of
being considered a wunderkind."
He goes to work for a
political newspaper.
He's super excited.
He gets to be in on
the issues of the day.
He gets to meet
senators, he gets
to have all these super cool
conversations and things.
But then he realizes,
especially when
he's having dinner with his
father, who was a journalist,
so what are you really doing?
What kind of work are you doing?
Where do you feel
you're adding value?
The more he peels
back the layers,
the more deflated he feels, the
less he likes the newspaper.
And he realizes this isn't
really a job for him.
It's not even a
career track for him.
And he is now
disengaged from that.
He's going to go to a public
policy program in the fall.
And he hopes to enter
into a career of politics.
It comes from a very good place.
He says, "I want to give
a little more to the world
than I take back."
And so it's all good.
But his expectation of being
the wunderkind-- that kid
who would be able to exceed all
expectations, that's a hard one
to manage.
It's a hard one as parents when
you place that on your kids
and it's a hard one for kids
who have their own expectations
that are quite large.
And I think it
doesn't always come
from a bad place in the parents.
We know that we know
our kids and we think
we want the best for them.
But it ends up being in a
bad place, because it ends up
putting pressure
that they already
feel upon themselves anyway.
So when you decide to
go do fill in the blank,
what will you hope
to get out of it?
If it turns out to be a path
that's not meaningful for you,
how will you know?
What's a milestone,
a measurement,
something that you
hope to get out of it
that's-- what's the marker
that you hope to see?
And if you don't see
that, what would you do?
I think the problem
is when we start
to place our answers on them
and they're not their answers.
But I think it's tricky.
And maybe we have some young
20-somethings in this room.
Does anybody want to
offer any thoughts
as to what we
could do, the older
generation, to be a little
more effective on this one?
AUDIENCE: I'm probably
actually not even old enough
for this book to apply,
because I'm only 19.
But I think one of the things
that a parent should do
is probably let their
kid have other role
models other than just parents
and relatives, and stuff
like that.
Because that's a really
good way for the kid
to be very isolated.
And they want to live the
expectations that their parents
have for them.
JILL EBSTEIN: Right.
So other role models and
really allowing their kids
to find other ways to
get their guidance?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
JILL EBSTEIN: That's
a great suggestion.
So the other part
about that is, once you
have this burden of
expectation, you go ahead
and you decide you're going
to try to go live up to it,
what do you do?
And so the contributors
in this book
do a series of what I call
experimentation and wandering
as they try to find their way.
There is a piece by
Carla Moody called
"A Series of New Beginnings."
And she describes graduating
college, having no money,
having to get a job as a
volunteer, living with her aunt
so she can basically
have free living.
And during lunchtime,
when people
might be able to
do something, she
just wanders the street walking,
because walking is free.
And she loves water.
She's a Pisces, she says.
So she looks at water fountains
and she entertains herself
in the cheapest,
freest way possible.
And from there, she just
said, I need some money.
She gets a nanny job.
From there, she goes
to work for Groupon.
From there, digital media.
She just wanders from
one job to the next.
Then she leaves Chicago
and she goes to Colorado.
And the last I spoke to her, she
said, every step along the way,
she learned something about what
she likes and what she doesn't.
And she now understands.
In this next job, she
thinks she'll last longer
and she thinks she'll have
a little longer road on it.
But wandering and
experimentation is the process.
And two things about that.
One is that I think if we were
to prepare our high school kids
and our college kids for this
is a trajectory that many
go through versus
thinking they're
going to have a
straight shot somewhere,
I think that would be helpful.
And I think if we
ourselves, as parents,
prepare ourselves for this
trajectory-- this windy,
and has starts and stops--
then that's helpful, too.
Because we place
less demands on them
and we place less
anxiety on ourselves,
which just ends up
meaning that everybody
feels the anxiety that we feel.
So that's an example.
But on the
experimentation piece--
I'm going to tell a story.
It was really funny.
So as you know, I asked,
give me a source of something
that means something to
you-- a poem, a song, a book.
And so I talked to this man
named Aaron Schoenfeldt, who
I've never met.
And he says to me,
oh, that's easy.
I love Camus's
interpretation of Sisyphus.
Wow.
Camus's interpretation
of Sisyphus.
Let me give you a little
background on Aaron.
He went to go work at City Year.
He graduated college.
He thought he'd be
a basketball player,
but his basketball career
wasn't as long as he thought.
So he studied anthropology and
he's all about giving back.
And he ended up
joining City Year
and going to Tulsa to teach.
He always had high
expectations of what
would happen when we
went to Tulsa to go
teach high schoolers.
And here's what he found.
So he starts off and he
says, "I spend most of my day
mentoring and
tutoring students who
are struggling with attendance,
behavior, and classwork.
I pulled students out
of class to give them
individualized support.
I met biweekly with students to
discuss behavior and attendance
goals for the week.
My services felt futile.
I could feel my activist
spirit dwindling."
And so then what happens?
He discovers, he
says, "I found out
that it was tough
to tell students
to do their homework when
their reason for not completing
the assignment was that they
have no time in between working
to support their families and
being the primary caregiver
to their young siblings."
So he was serving a very
impoverished disenfranchised
community.
And education in
the classic sense
of what he was trying to teach
them was just not possible.
And so then he remembered Camus.
And you know "The
Myth of Sisyphus"
is the boulder that
you're trying to push up
and then it ends up coming down.
And the myth-- in Camus's
interpretation, the meaning
is in the struggle to
continue pushing up,
and he says, to fight the
nihilistic tendencies of oh
is futile.
And you have to find meaning
in the everyday grind of doing
the job and moving
things forward
and the challenge of it all
versus the outcome of it all.
And so he says, "In Camus,
the most important thing
is that we continue to believe
in the world and in ourselves,
and in the struggle
there is meaning."
So he completely reframes his
job and he alters his method.
"I changed to a more
practical approach, hoping
to meet students closer
to where they were,
instead of where I
wanted them to be."
And he describes what he does,
and he says, "All of a sudden,
the students were
improving their attendance,
their behavior, their skills."
And he says, "All
was not exhausted.
My boulder awaited
me every morning."
But he was OK with it, that
the challenge and the value
was in that push.
And so I think that
experimentation is just
part of the process.
And that just like
with Aaron Schoenfeldt
and with Carla Moody, you
have to understand and expect
the fact that it's going to
be fits and starts and a lot
of learning along the way.
So the last thing I want to
talk about is affirmation.
So you go through
all this process,
you deal with rejection.
And it's not sequential.
But you deal with rejection,
you get yourself relatively
in a healthy place, you
manage your expectations
and/or your family's
expectations,
you're figuring out
what you want to do.
But the end game is that you
can affirm what you're doing,
and as one of the contributors
says, how to love myself,
that you really affirm
what you're about
and that it has meaning
to you, and that you
can feel positive and go forward
with whatever your mission is.
So Esther Steinberg
is a comedian.
And she's 28 years old.
And she is used to being--
when she gets on
stage, sometimes it's
a friendly audience, sometimes
it's not a friendly audience.
You work hard to
even get on stage.
She was on a sitcom
series for a while.
That got canceled.
She has dealt with a
series of rejections
that makes it hard for her
to continue to move forward.
And yet, there's
nothing else she
wants to do in life but
comedy and entertainment.
So she goes into therapy to
work her way through depression.
And I'm going to
read you the story
that her therapist tells her.
And I want a take from
you guys of whether this
would be comforting to you.
I think it's curious.
"One day my therapist spent our
entire session telling me this
long story about a movie called
'Queen of the Nile,' which I
had never seen.
It's about a missionary
who goes to Africa.
Somehow the missionary and
a man end up on a small boat
and they sail for safety.
They both die on the boat after
a series of terrible events.
And right before the
end of the movie,
the camera zooms out and reveals
that they were only a couple
of feet from safety.
My therapist told me
that woman was me."
OK.
So stop.
First of all, would that
make you feel better?
Hands up if it makes
you feel better
to know that the shoreline
was right there next to you.
It's hard for me to imagine.
But here's what she says.
She said, "I was
feeling desperate.
I didn't go to a therapist
to hear him recap a movie,
but somehow as low as I was and
feeling as desperate as I was,
hearing this story brought
me a glimmer of hope.
My take-- when you
are in a moment that
is difficult and
gloomy, sometimes it
helps to hear someone
else say you are so close
and you can't even see it."
So for her, that
story emboldened her.
And she felt like there was
hope, that shoreline was right
next to her and she kept on.
And she's actually
doing very well.
She's on a series of shows
and comedies going on.
But she uses that as a moment.
And she realized she has
to really just a affirm
herself and remind
yourself that she is good,
her skills are good, she can
get there if she wants to.
OK.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]